many of the Disney princes are born into
royalty but some become royal through
marriage and some aren't actually royal
at all get the lowdown on all the Disney
Princesses love interests and keep
watching to the end to discover which
prince was born royal but never knew it
I was that an official wish say the
magic words
truly I wish for you to make me a prince
the prince from Snow White
we're beginning with the movie that
started the whole Disney Princess
franchise and that's Snow White in the
Seven Dwarfs Snow White's love interest
was simply called the Prince so it's
pretty clear from the get-go that this
guy was royal from birth and Snow White
was also born royal so these two
lovebirds are as regal as they come
there's been speculation through the
years about what his actual name is some
think it's Ferdinand because of a
comment Shirley Temple made in the 1938
Oscars when she presented Walt Disney
with his awards others think it's
frederick because that name is
reportedly used in artwork and documents
in the Walt Disney studio archives and
others think it's Florian and that name
was allegedly used when Disney started
its princess franchise regardless of his
real name there are other fascinating
facts about the prince that shed light
on the whole franchise their friends has
the honor of being the first realistic
human male that Disney animators brought
to the screen if you think back to the
start of Disney Animation it's all
anthropomorphic characters like Mickey
Mouse because of his groundbreaking
position the prince was actually the
hardest of all characters to animate and
that's why he only had a minor role in
the film
in fact he's only in it twice animator
Milt Kahl was involved in bringing the
prince to life and that gave him
valuable experience for the next two
entries on our list
Prince Charming Milt Kahl also had a
different task of animating the love
interest in Cinderella Prince Charming
has plenty in common with the prince
from Snow White
he was born royal and he only had a
small role in his movie we see Prince
Charming at the ball and when he tries
to find the girl whose foot fits the
slipper finally we see him leaving their
wedding that's not much air time at all
we also never know his name although
it's thought that he's called Henry but
there are crucial differences between
the two princes the first is that Prince
Charming married a woman who wasn't
already broiled Cinderella became royal
through marriage rather than birth
another difference between the men in
these two movies is that Prince Charming
gets a much bigger role in his sequels
particularly in Cinderella 3 a twist in
time someone else in Cinderella we also
get to learn more about what life is
like for a prince born into royalty his
father the king is desperate for his son
to find a wife he's also very keen to
have grandchildren running around the
castle that's why the King comes up with
the idea of a ball so that his son can
meet every eligible maiden in the
kingdom
in fact the king is so determined to
find a wife for a son that he doesn't
restrict the choices to royalty only
that's not like our next royal entries
father Prince Phillip Prince Phillip is
also royal by birth he continued with
the prince and Snow White began by
saving a damsel in distress with true
love's kiss but he's actually the first
Disney Prince to be known by his actual
name
in fact it's thought that Aurora's bow
was named after a real Prince that's
Prince Phillip the husband of the UK's
Queen Elizabeth the second difference in
Sleeping Beauty is also the first love
interest to have a prominent role in his
movie this film also features Prince
Philip's father King Hubert and were
shown how young prince's lives are
controlled by their families from a very
young age in this case King Hubert and
his vesti King Stefan decide that their
children should get married when they're
old enough given that Aurora is only a
baby at the time and Phillip just a
young boy it's not like they had any say
in the matter
Phillip and Aurora fall in love for real
and
they meet many years later and they
don't even realize they're betrothed
Philip assumes Aurora is a peasant girl
but that doesn't stand in the way of his
feelings for her
he manipulates his father into agreeing
that he should marry the girl he loves
as it turns out of course they're both
royalty and have been promised to each
other forever
that all works out well in the end
didn't it Prince Eric before the prince
in the Disney Princess franchise was
also born royal Prince Eric from The
Little Mermaid marries a princess who
was born royal too however King Triton
is the king of the sea making Ariel a
princess from a different realm this
couple goes on to have a child called
melody in their sequel movie so they're
a royal family through and through and
that makes Eric the only Disney Prince
to be a father but we don't actually
know that much about Eric's lineage to
find out more about Eric's background we
have to take a look at the 2007 Broadway
musical adaptation of the Disney film in
it we learned that Eric's father has
passed away and it's Eric's manservant
Grimm's bees duty to help him find a
bride this is so that Eric can return to
the throne properly despite his love of
exploring the sea grimsey also takes on
this role in the movie when he gives
Eric a birthday present Grimsby says
that he wishes it were a wedding present
instead we discover that Eric had
recently refused to marry a princess
from another land and Grimsby remarks
that he as well as the entire kingdom
wants to see Eric happily married Eric
however will only marry when he finds
the right girl and that girl turns out
to be Ariel of course Prince Adam the
next Prince in the franchise is only in
his true Prince form at the very end of
his movie we're talking about Prince
Adam aka beasts from Beauty and the
Beast although he was born royal and
enchantress transformed him into a beast
because of his less than regal attitude
he had to learn to love and earn Belle's
love in return to break the curse and
also to earn back his human and princely
status interestingly although he's
referred to as Prince in the opening
then of the characters directly for
to him by that title and the first draft
also indicated that he was a Duke rather
than a prince we don't get much more
information about his royal background
in the animated movie but we do discover
some interesting backstory in the 2017
live-action remake a flashback reveals
that he had a kind-hearted mother who
passed away when he was a child his
cruel father was left to raise him which
meant he developed cruel behavior as a
result as for his name Adam is an
unofficial moniker even though it has
been used in some licensed merchandise
in fact it was stated in the director's
commentary on the DVD release that the
character never had an actual name
he's only referred to as the beast or
the prince it's been said that this lack
of name is simply down to the writers
and producers being so busy they forgot
to give him one Aladdin it's taken us
until the sixth love interest in the
Disney Princess franchise to find a man
that wasn't born royal Aladdin has the
honour of being the first Prince that
became royal through marriage in fact at
the beginning of the movie he couldn't
get much further from royalty if he
tried the self-confessed street rat and
thief had to steal food to survive
there aren't many Prince's that need to
do that but the words prince and
princess aren't necessarily the right
fit here after all Jasmine's father was
a sultan so by marrying Jasmine in the
sequel did Aladdin actually become a
sultan rather than a prince of course
Aladdin does become a prince temporarily
but not through birth or marriage he
becomes Prince Ali Ababwa thanks to
genie who grants his wish to be a prince
this was all part of a Lyons plan to get
Jasmine to fall in love with him
Aladdin also has the honour of being the
first love interest in the Disney
Princess franchise to have the movie
named entirely after him so with the
release of the movie Aladdin in 1992 we
saw a couple of major shifts the first
was giving the attention to the male
character and the second was his lack of
royal birthright status
li Shang unlike the rest of the Disney
princes li Shang is neither born a
prince nor does he marry into royalty
that's because his eventual wife in the
sequel Mulan isn't actually a princess
she's the eighth official Disney
princess but unlike most of the other
princesses she's not actually royal
through birth or marriage she's
recognized for her heroic acts rather
than any royal status the character was
in fact inspired by the legendary figure
from the Chinese poem The Ballad of Hua
Mulan as for general li Shang rather
than being a prince he is actually a
captain in the Chinese army just like
his father general lead so from that
point of view he carries on the same
title as his father just like a prince
and King would but unlike royalty li
Shang earns his title through hard work
and training rather than it being a
birthright prince naveen with the 2009
movie The Princess and the Frog we saw
the return of a prince who was born
royal but Prince Naveen didn't actually
act a regal to begin with and he's very
different than the golden age Disney
princes that were used to
whereas Prince Naveen was portrayed as
being a freeloader and a party animal
who had spent all of his life being
waited on the prince of maldonia 'he's
parents were so unimpressed by his
spoiled attitude and laziness that they
cut him off and so he was on the hunt
for a rich woman to marry that's another
shift in the franchise as the male love
interest that went before him all wanted
to marry for love even Aladdin who
certainly would have benefited from
marrying into money its Tiana who
transforms Naveen into a worthier man
and he transforms her into a princess
when they get married and it's thanks to
this regal transformation that they both
transform back into humans it's like an
updated version of the true love kiss
but the franchise started out with they
helped each other in different ways
rather than one character entirely
saving the other they worked together to
create the restaurant and the Veen lives
life as a hard-working employee rather
than a spoiled Prince Eugene Fitzherbert
we're finishing up with the love
interest that became royal through
marriage and then discovered he was in
fact a secret prince after all
Rapunzel's love interest in tangled had
a split identity throughout the movie
already he
Alfa's Flynn writer but he's actually
called Eugene Fitzherbert and we assume
that the former thief gains his royal
status entirely through marriage to the
Princess Rapunzel and Eugene both
assumed that was the case too but
actually Eugene is the only Disney
Prince to be a long-lost prince and this
is revealed not in the original movie or
a sequel film but in the animated TV
show tangled the series in the season 2
finale of what became Rapunzel's tangled
adventure
Eugene finds out that he is the
long-lost son of King Evans ruler of the
Dark Kingdom King Edmund explains that
when Eugene was little a powerful opal
threatened to destroy the land the king
ordered a kingdom wide evacuation to
protect his subjects including Eugene
who was placed in an orphanage the opal
led to Eugene's mother passing away and
presented a risk to Rapunzel to Eugene's
unknown royal lineages is parallel with
Rapunzel's own journey after all she was
the lost princess of Corona and also
didn't know her royal birthright so now
you know which Disney princes were born
royal which married royalty and which
weren't royal at all which is your
favorite Disney friends let us know in
the comment section below thanks for
watching give this video a big thumbs up
if you love Disney and make sure to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one we'll see you next time
[Music]